how did you go from being a kid wealthy
neighborhood next thing you know you're
getting arrested rocker island you have
a issue with Mike Tyson with the gun
what is the chip come from I can't
figure out the chip with you teddy when
I go on a Dairy Queen we're going to
fight courage is facing something and
there's nothing to overcome nothing to
face what would coverage be that's a
powerful statement you just made and cuz
he would tell me the allele
you're a born reader when you saw
Sammy's response was a percent akin to
memory so that I know his partner was a
guy named John Gotti we want to get into
the boxing business you put down at Dana
who's the better promoter you know what
helps to be a dictator sometimes I just
don't have that some of these fights
right now you're watching a for what all
the fears all the doubts all the
inhibitions all the crap that happened
to us as a kid and then our one given
night he could get in the ring and if
you're prepared enough if you determined
enough if you care enough you can be
called champion of the world
[Music]
today I have a special guest with me
Teddy Atlas who is a powerhouse in the
ESPN world when it comes down to a
commentator on top of that he's part of
the World Boxing Hall of Fame and he's
trained Tysons Michael Moore just an
incredible resume and we're thankful for
Teddy making the time to come out here
in Dallas Texas appreciate meeting you
yes it's good to miss you behind you you
like the picture behind this is quite a
diverse crowd can you can you name em
all yeah I understand the guy with power
and Kennedy and Lincoln and Tupac and
you of course dr. Martin Luther King and
so the guy next to Martin Luther King a
lot of people think that's Warren
Buffett but that's Milton Friedman the
economist and then the guy standing next
to me is a racecar driver Ayrton Senna
and then the man sitting down as a Shah
beer on Reza Pahlavi all right so yes
with all those medals on them yeah I
mean it's it speaks to what to you a
little bit I guess why you got someone
like me in here you you go all over the
place why have a person like you in here
I mean you're you're a guy that when it
comes into the world of boxing and
people see you as a scientist the way
you see the boxing your lens the way you
view there's a complete different lens
and a lot of people out there yeah so
the question I got the more I you know
go through your story and obviously a
part of why you're here is the Sammy the
bubbles we'll get to later on in a
minute because of what Sammy said about
your relationship with them and you got
a whole chapter on Sammy we'll talk
about that here in a minute but how did
you go from being a kid raising a family
your dad's a doctor
your mom's a Miss America pageant Staten
Island wait wealthy neighborhood and
then next thing you know you're getting
arrested rocker island you become a
boxer then you get into a fight with an
executive and you have a issue with Mike
Tyson with the gun then you're going
after your one your boxers to the
apartment at night because of what
happened within Gallagher you know all
what is the chip come
I can't figure out the chip with you
teddy you don't have to be from the
projects or poverty you know to be
missing something or searching for
something and then again you can be from
the projects or poverty and you're not
missing anything and you don't have to
search for anything you know it all
depends on what we've been affected by
what we care about you know what do you
care about obviously you care about
things that are attached to different
things with your background and we had a
little brief talk before you care about
your father
mm-hmm well a lot of sons care about
their fathers and you never know to what
extent to what extremity what extreme
that it is until you know do you driven
somewhere you know and you don't know
what's driving you you just know what
you feel I mean listen it's easier for
me now to act like I'm smart when I'm a
little older and I understand where I
went and maybe a little bit about how I
got there at that point when I was going
I was just going I didn't know why but I
was being drawn by something I had a
father you just touched on you know we
lived in a good neighborhood gave us
everything we needed I didn't I was a
big sports guy when I was a kid like a
lot of us but Mickey Mantle and Willie
Mays and Muhammad Ali they were all my
heroes I liked them a lot
I looked up to those guys but they want
my heels I didn't even know what he was
but as I got older I guess if I had a
hero it was my father but he didn't talk
like Ali and make predictions Oh at home
ones like you know like demented or
catch balls the way that really did over
his head but you know he got up in the
morning and he wouldn't took care of
people and he didn't come back in too
late at night when I was sleeping and he
put a white pillow under his tongue one
time when I was a kid and I didn't even
know that that was nitroglycerine
because his heart was starting to pop a
little bit but it was more important
that he did his job and he still saw his
patients and it was if he he collapsed
so um you know like he didn't talk but
he he he produced he did and I saw and
when you're kids you see things hmm
you know and I saw what he was doing I
saw what he was
I opened up the door one time without
without knocking I said enough but um
it's part of you part of what you do you
know you you take different steps and
you just go and I opened up the door
there was a mirror there and he was over
here so I could see him without opened
all the way and he didn't have a chance
to react and he was bent over in pain
wearing a harness I didn't know what it
was it was a trust you know that was
keeping his intestines in place because
he had a double hernia back in the day
when you couldn't do it with lasers and
all that stuff and you know he got mad
at me for coming in without knocking as
soon as he saw that that somebody was
there he was good he was he wasn't in
pain no more so I was only about nine
years old I guess but I realized at that
point it was always in pain but he
didn't show it because we're getting
away of what he had to do don't show
pain no excuses do what you're supposed
to do and he went and he took care of
people all day and didn't come home to
midnight and he did house calls so he's
80 and he did him for free and he went
into the projects because people
couldn't afford a doctor and he built
two hospitals one of them at 22 beds in
it and he built it so before Obamacare
and all this other stuff they talk about
you know what they can't figure it out
he figured it out himself in a small way
you know he'd built a house but only
took care of the people and the people
couldn't afford it he he covered it you
know he absorbed it on the arm like we
like to say back in old days but the
people that could afford a day in
insurance paid the bills and that has
for a lasted for 24 years and so it got
torn down by the city because they had
to built a bridge called the Verrazano
Bridge on San huh but I didn't get him
enough I was selfish all right so he
wasn't around enough yeah yeah he was
around in the way he was but you know he
took care of the bills to care
everything and you know I saw what I saw
but as a kid
you know I wanted to play ball with him
I want to I know it sounds stupid but
you know because there's kids that
suffer a lot more than me but who's to
equate what suffering is to a kid who's
to make sure that how do you measure
yeah I'd like to know how do you measure
that that there might be a kid in the
project something a lot more than me a
lot more there's rats running around and
he's got no food I'm with you I'm with
you but suffering is suffering and not
having it's not having what did you know
what do we really need for me I needed I
guess I needed my father to just say
you're doing good say say hey I'm gonna
be that stupid but I love you
you ever hear that I couldn't do it
because you know he had to be he was a
real tough guy these big-ass tough guys
you mentioned one earlier it's okay
but he was a real tough guy you know
because he did what he had to do no
matter how he felt and no matter what
could get away nitroglycerine didn't get
away nothing getting away he did what he
was supposed and in his selfless way and
when I couldn't get that attention from
him I started to figure out it's the
genius that I was as a young kid and I'm
making fun of myself because I wasn't
too bright I I figured hey who gets
almost attention all the people that are
hurt all the people that are fractured
all the people that are screwed all this
sense of oh all the people that are
damaged so you know what I'll go and
damage myself I'll go from this nice
neighborhood did you just say I'll go
down to a neighborhood that's not as
maybe nice in some ways and I start
getting damaged but I also found family
in that neighborhood I found I found in
some of those rough places people that
that were drawn together and I didn't
feel that I had that without my father
and so I go I went got damaged and um
like I said my father was not a BS
artist my father was a doctor bizarre he
was a special guy I mean when I got this
on my face because I was an idiot and
I'm out there
you know thinner streets and I'm
fighting and not everyone fights with
the hands
I don't fighting a few guys and one of
them still wanted to pull a knife and
you know I got 400 stitches to an eye
and listen I wish I didn't have another
stitches yeah 200 insite 200 outside and
you know I don't want this you know but
sometimes it's the part of if you pick a
path that that has a lot of sticker
bushes in it you could get hit with
sticker bushes and I got hit with knifes
and when when it happened they would
taken me to the hospital and I remember
the only reason I got taken there so
quickly was the kid that was with me
from from the neighborhood that I was
hanging out in he was a streetwise kid
he jumped over the counter of a bodega
and he said a cop was shot and so we got
attention really fast you know and they
think they got there real quick and I
was so the cops thought I was gonna die
because I heard them you know I heard
him say I think we might lose him
because you know you bleeding a lot and
um when we were driving and obviously
Miko here I remember I was really
coherent it's amazing how clear
you've been true love for things for me
you in the army and thank you for that
service and you faced worse things to me
but I was so clear it was like hey I
ain't worried about not the only thing I
was thinking about was what is my father
doing at this time is he in between
house calls come on
yeah that's what you were saying yeah is
he in between let me try to figure you
know because y'all screwed up you gotta
cut here flee you know your your a
little messed up but I'm thinking is he
is he doing a house call or is he still
in office now or is he maybe in the
hospital like could you how long will it
take him to get here did you want it to
see it did you okay I'll always said to
them I was telling the cops and they
said just you know just relax don't talk
and I kept I just kept saying here you
gotta get docked at with
I hit take care of this and when we got
there they put me on a stretch and
they're shooting stuff into me and
they're taking me in and I guess it's
just a moment perform out you know and
and as I'm going in the surgeon is over
me and I guess he was because not
everyone's wearing a mask unless right
he's talking to me and I'm just saying
to him listen I'm not saying you're not
I still had some - I'm just like I'm not
saying you're not a good doctor but get
dr. Halas he had take care of this and
and they were like they were good
doctors in a way that not just with the
stitches they were good doctors because
they understood they had a young kid he
they know he was your father was they
said they said we know doc that was he's
a great doctor but we don't have time
they said that to me we don't have time
and they were they were honest and we
don't have time I said no no no get him
go to you at this time
I was saw let's say I went up to custom
Otto's when I was 19 and and then I went
up then and I came back and when I came
back after year up there this happened
so I was like 28 21 and then when it was
over with this is the point I was trying
to get to with my father the kind of man
he was and I don't want people hey
listen you think what you think people
gonna when I tell you this they're gonna
say oh he's a cold man no he was and he
was a it was a real man it was a
realistic man he knew what he was
dealing with he he I was laying man I
guess I came out of it after a while you
know I was obviously sedated and it was
a doc and I mean you know I got a thing
around me and I'm thin man I'm just
thinking when is when's he gonna get
here
and all of a sudden a curtain opened up
and I couldn't really see him but I knew
it was him
he had big aunts strong hands and
I just remember Moe for me I remember he
just turned my head a little bit because
he was on this side just turned it and
see he would know how to turn it without
having worried about hurting you you
know and he just turned it and all he
said was they did a good job you're
gonna have the skull for life and he
left and that was it
you know and I guess that was part of my
travel back to being a human being that
I could be like I am now because it
didn't get me what I wanted it to get me
you know so then it was just a matter
after that of finding your way you know
and thankfully uh you know with the help
of some people and the help of boxing
and maybe myself a little bit hey I got
to the right place you know I got to the
right place impressive for you to go
from that to where you are today man I
mean that's very very impressive to have
turned it around that way that you and
him ever have a sit-down relationship
like last members of your pops what was
the last conversation you had with your
pops he was 88 years old he did house
calls to his 80 free house calls and he
had to get hip surgery he was in a lot
of pain I never saw anyone who could
tolerate pain like him and it got to the
point where I was real bad so he went in
for hip replacement and his heart wasn't
great so the doctors he billed to
hospitals he built he built Sunnyside
Hospital the one I told you about then
the bridge was built so they had to they
had to buy it from them and tear it down
put the highway there and anyone built
doctors hospital but 60 doctors but he
was the founder and
that hospital s at 35 years and that's
the hospital he gets hip surgery in and
when he went forward some of the doctors
said you you shouldn't because your
heart you know in 88 and he said listen
I you know I want to get it because
obviously he understood the pain and so
he went in they went in on Friday the
13th and we break them I know this
sounds so superstitious my mother's
Irish besides being beautiful she's
Irish so you're gonna excuse the
superstition so and so she we we said go
on another day Friday the 13th is as
good as anything so he went in he went
in and had a massive heart attack and
you know all the doctors the main taxes
were gone for the weekend
see it was fine 2:30 and they walk on
because it's the weekend yeah so there
was an intern there and I know this
sounds like but hey look sometimes the
truth sounds like something that you add
it to but it is what it is oh that old
saying you can't make this stuff right
he um the intern came in and he very
quietly said I'm having him I'm gonna
have a massive heart attack heart attack
he said give me 200 cc's of heparin now
I don't know how many cc's I'm just
saying but I think it was heparin
actually it's a blood thinner and he
understood he was a great doctor and
then the intern said I can't you just
had hip surgery you would hemorrhage and
he said to him you don't worry about
saving the brakes when you're gonna lose
the engine always thinking calm cool
even though ain't no and the guy said I
can't I can't
an hour later for heart attack and never
fully recovered from it and I had a
million tubes set up to him at the track
to trach you know all the tubes and
everything and
obviously every day you know supposed to
be and that was the only time I could
talked because he couldn't talk about
you know and then I don't doing that
time I just
there was a story written by Jerry
Eisenberg the great writer he wrote a
story in the new Star Ledger and it was
a story that I talked to Jerry and the
story was funny were talking about is I
didn't realize well god what real tough
guys are about your dad yeah but that
was the headline in store a while what a
real tough guy is and here's this guy in
the hospital and Jerry talked and then
me you know talk about the people I've
been around maybe the guy different guys
like the kind of guys you just mentioned
earlier and um but they're not tough
guys here's a tough guy and you know and
just talked about him and his life and
what he did and then I read the story
talk but he was already gone
I don't know if he can hear it but at
the end of it you know I just you know
at the end of it I said like in this
story I read the story to him and in the
end of it I say I love you and you know
I'm not gonna lie to you it'd be more
it'd be more better I know that's not
the proper word but who cares
it would be better if I knew he heard it
it would be gutsy on my part how much
guts do I have that I had to wait until
he was seven comments awesome on that
not too much guts not too much house but
you know I I told it to him and I know
again you know he wasn't completely gone
and I thought I saw some smile I don't
know you know we don't know right you
don't know maybe you just want to see so
maybe that's but I thought I did by
doing it and um you know you hold on to
those things I guess but you know they
get you where you need to get to
sometimes but on this your standard of
tough guy like I see you see a man's man
- you like the
watch your life you've been around a lot
of I don't like straw man put that way
like I don't use the word stand up guy
because I've seen too many I'm gonna sit
down I don't want to get I said because
you've never seen it with your dad your
dad's always stay consistent tough never
shown it you don't want to hear stand up
because I don't know what it is I don't
I did it's just a word
Sheldon show me show me show me
I love one time I was acting like a jerk
and then I'm in the streets fighting and
I get you know I get cracked in the back
for the tire hey that you picked the
streets they ain't to any rules it's
kind of like it's kind of like MMA
except they don't hit you a pipe stay
there and they face you some people
don't face you so in the middle of all
this fighting I get hit for the tire and
what do I do I go to his office to get
stitched up thinking I'm like like I'm
some kind of hero like I could won like
I'm a I could walk in get stitched up
and go out and get an act like a fool
you know and so I walk in some one of my
friends who just would do anything I
said at that point so walking me in I'm
bleeding all over the place and the
place is packed because my father had
the biggest practice that was in New
York because - everybody knew your
father at that there he was a well-known
doctor you had to wait five six hours to
see him and people didn't mind seven
hours because they were gonna see this
doctor
and listen some of his part he's the
only one who would take everyone let's
see if you're gonna talk truth you told
truth
he took everyone he took anyone who
needed health care and a lot of doctors
you know they wouldn't take everyone
they wouldn't take the drug addicts who
needed a little help or you know they
all other people that had no insurance
because there was plenty of people that
no insurance so anyway he I get past the
line thinking on the big shot I won't
pass the line he sees me you know oh he
comes in the nurse of course sees me and
she's like oh come on Teddy you know
thinking she's doing the right thing and
she's
to me and past all these poor people
that have been waiting and he looks down
the hall he sees me he says wait like
everyone else done a little wait after
waiting it was a short day it was a
probably about four hours so after
waiting he brings me in I'm a mess
no thinking I did some overall work you
know we get you know we get stupid and I
get in there and she gets the thing back
in those days I see it big syringe of
novocaine and she's handing it told me
he goes what's that for
very very simple man very simple but not
like just what's that for
she said it's it's know the game is oh
he doesn't want that if he's gonna live
this way you should know how it feels he
doesn't want that and I was like wow of
course I don't
Wow and and you know so listen again
some people out there gonna are gonna
say that this guy was cold it was this
is the same guy who got surgery that the
Bernie I talked about after 30 years of
carrying it around he finally got
surgery back in the days when they
couldn't do it the way they do it now
and he was supposed to be in the house
for over a week probably eight nine days
he was in there for one day checks out
and goes back to work how do you do that
that's a tough guy how do you do that
got it and now he paid a price for it
because the smart man doesn't mean that
he does smart things for himself all the
time years lady had to get another
surgery but he was able to get back to
work why because he knew he could yeah
he knew it would hurt he know it wasn't
practical but he knew he could could we
can tolerate things we can do things
every day but he was doing it for other
people not for himself and that's a
tough guy did mom and I stay married
they were there they stayed married yeah
so mom was totally for Mom khatallah mom
could be around it all the time
you know I mean in some ways but look
mom mom look can good for you not ready
to talk you shouldn't put yourself in
front of one of these things I guess
my mother was drinking a bit you know
and I'm sure that some of these things
add it to you know add it to relief a
little relief and escape and escape mm
ah what a good woman good woman sir but
the aunt is that the opposite of my
father my mother was beautiful gorgeous
I mean she was Miss staredown her mother
would let her go to Miss America and she
was supposed to go to Miss America you
know the Rockettes wanted her to try out
for them for them I mean she was
gorgeous
and it's but she was social she was she
had as gorgeous is she was that's how
electric her personality was she loved
people loved them
my father was working on my father was
just like you know he didn't take
vacations he didn't go to these parties
and social events and all that he was in
the office he was on a house call he was
he was in the nursing homes nursing
homes have to have back in those days
they had to have doctors that were on
them that was signed in as a medical
director they didn't have money but they
had to have a doctor as a medical
tonight they couldn't pay him hmm so my
father was a medical directive like nine
nursing homes because because someone
had to do it so they couldn't write so
he didn't take no money but since he did
it he figured that he had to show up or
he should show up to see that the people
aren't being abused you talk about being
back in those days there would be a lot
easier to abuse people who was who was
checking who was checking nowadays you
got everything you got somebody might
have his cell phone and catch your muse
and so on okay you don't need NBC so he
he's going all these nursing homes doing
all this stuff and my mother is you know
it's tough you know and he's not enough
that he's going to the hospital not
enough that he's got his office hours
not enough that he's doing house calls
but but now he's going to nursing homes
to make sure you know that that stuff
was he an immigrant was he I know he's
he polishes your mana hungry Hong Kong
and my mother family came from Ireland
and so so but not that they they were
here but you went to Poland you can't be
you why did you go to pol I went to
Poland I went to Quetta wits and Cracow
I spent a month over there to do a movie
with Willem Dafoe oh okay I got it got
it so your your your mom and dad was
your dad an immigrant or was you've
known here he was warning of Carens he
was born his parents came and got one
was his birthday just out of curiosity
was it was his birthday January 19th
January 19th and when are you your days
after Muhammad Ali January 19 to this
and your June 28th when is July 29 July
so he's two days after Ali January 19th
interesting did you did you feel like I
was always told me capricorns with
special people he said was he one or no
yes he was he was one okay what's he one
is one that he paid attention to stuff
we're not really unboxing your
superstitions that he did but he didn't
believe in like Venus being math the
math okay I believe that certain
characteristics were inherent in certain
science Wow
and I like him already there is no
interest yeah and he told me you know
you had to saw me he wasn't paying me I
was in the gym you every when I was up
there seven years with him I was open to
gym training finest seven days a week he
didn't believe in taking some that he's
off and you know every day every day
closed one today
averages at night I grab a cheeseburger
and go right to the averages be there to
ten o'clock at night and you know to the
last kid was gone talk to the kids with
their problems
besides teach them how to throw a jab
you know whatever and cuz would tell me
cuz would say yo Leo you're a born
leader I said yeah I'm a born winner
yeah he goes yeah he goes you look at
history and he would read it it wasn't
just making it I think it said look I've
got all the leaders gone they were Leo
this one was a Leo and I was like
thinking my head you know I I hope guys
like in a woman I mean you're gonna have
some crazies no matter what you are
good the booster yes like Alexander the
Great I don't know how bad he was as a
but Alexander that'd be a million square
miles economy yeah cusp was a guy that
paid attention today
did he ever kind of hint that who he
felt would make great boxers or no
wasn't that yes what money things
certain styles a certain months what
month was his Aquarius was one or
February yeah another one was Capricorn
I have an ally baby you know and Taurus
the Bull was Morris yeah he said some of
them made pretty good fighters he told
me Pisces would make good teachers so if
I had a Pisces guy I'd be like thinking
of it spending all this time with the
guy and he's gonna be a teacher tiny bit
like a little teeny teeny bit like you
know I wouldn't because you put a lot of
time miss Tyson's birthday but when I
say his potassium was June to 30th so so
cancer oh he's kiss a month before he's
handsome he said cancers were good so
he's the cancers was good to know it did
he say Aquarius were good because they
were most coachable and willing to be
taught and they could control themselves
because that's a big quality we're all
about controlling emotions you know be
that were being common and uncommon
place-- being common and on comple so
how many similarities between your
father and between cus you know my
father didn't talk cuz talked because
taught you how to articulate things my
father told you by doing that because it
wasn't real he was he was a special man
a great man but because because had some
flaws my father didn't have and at the
end of the day you know cuz was in a
race against you know time and against
death maybe where you know he wanted to
have another champion and he lit a few
things go and with Tyson and I'm Noddin
I understand it better now because if I
was in the same position what would I
have done I don't know I don't know if I
was in a position cuz was where I had
tooth
I had world champions before and my
whole life was boxing I
nothing else I never got married I only
married boxing everything was about
legacy everything was about attach to
that and I had one special guy and I was
getting old I was getting closer to
dying and I needed this guy to fulfill
to make everything worthwhile what would
I do
and and coz let a few things go and but
my father didn't let none go my father
never made deals deals meaning what
feels like I couldn't when cuz cuz let's
end behavior with Tyson Cole even the
way he treated him was you're not gonna
hear about you know the way Tyson
treated cuz yeah God wasn't always so
good I'm not here no was he patient than
tolerant is that because cus understood
that maybe he's going through a maturity
level or he came from a tough place
Tyson from Brownsville where he had to
be understood those things that where he
the way he was brought up that you had
to have tolerance and understanding and
appreciation for where he came from but
there's still things that that you draw
a line with when when you and school in
the hallway and you're pushing goes into
the bathroom in the middle of a busy
always just banging them into the
bathroom so you could touch them and to
other whatever and and yeah going
against teachers and getting physical
and doing some other things you know I
mean I don't think it's a secret now I
think that you know he and then you you
along you go and talk to the principal
and saying we have a special kid here
he's gonna make the town of famous you
know he's gonna make history and he
could be a very very very special
fighter
oh you I don't know you doing more than
making allowances you doing more than
understanding that there's going to be
some understanding for the specialness
of this Cayden of things that he's
suffering from and the things that he
can't quite get grips on you know you're
not really helping him get a grip on it
you helping him avoid right I mean that
becomes avoidance more than it becomes
you know helping somebody get better at
something and listen again it's easy for
me I was in that gym 18 19 years old
training fighters cuz would come once a
week maybe once every two weeks
just to see what was going on and and I
was just working training fighters
developing finest and cus would give me
the he didn't give me money but he gave
me the food he gave me the nourishment I
need he gave me what I need he would
come and say look at this atlases
developing and he's developing a staple
of fighters here look at what he's doing
and I felt so good you know I felt so
big and I was developing these fighters
and doing a job because we come like I
said one step twice a week he would call
me he'd overlook it and he'd see it and
make me feel very proud and it was a
special guy and all that then all of a
sudden when the Tyson came along we had
rules where I made the rules if a kid
felt subjects in school he would stay
out of the gym till he got caught up
with that subject and pass that
something and you know so we had these
rules that made sense not just as
humanitarians that's not trying to paint
ourselves like we're well open the Hmong
calcia but but how you gonna get parents
from a small town to a lot of their kids
to go if you're not looking out for the
kid more than just teaching them to get
a flat nose hopefully not get a flat
nose hopefully we slip the punches we
don't get them but you know you gotta be
doing more so part of it made sense that
we did care about them but I'm just
saying that it made sense to take that
approach just say hey they got to do
good in school they got to behave
outside the gym they got it too so we
had all these rules when when Tyson
started having problems in school a and
I throw him out of the gym the same way
as I did the other kids cuz would let
him back in and you know it started for
the first time me and him started he he
didn't back me up for the first time
ever you felt undermine
and listen again you gotta remember I
was a young kid I was in there training
and because helped me and he saved me
because I was an idiot out on the street
and if it wasn't for him and my father
because my father was paying for me to
be up there it was only 15 hours a week
but I didn't have 15 hours a week
III didn't have 200 a month and you know
he was I remember cuz would say to me
cuz you know you'd have to pay a lot
more for a college education because you
getting a college education it's just
that it's in this I said yeah sounds
right you know and and all I'm doing is
I'm doing what I'm supposed to do I'm
teaching a kid to move his head after he
punches I'm teaching a kid to understand
range the distance I'm teaching a kid to
controls feelings not to give in not to
submit not to make sound learn
agreements like when you get inside and
and you don't feel like working what do
you do you put your hands behind the guy
the guy holds onto you silent agreement
because you know you know that the guy
most likely will hold on to you because
you don't hit me I won't hit you you're
basically saying hey get it so you
supposed hit the guy right you put your
hands behind them maybe if the guy's a
little weak and hold on to you and now
you told them if you don't hit me I
won't hit you silent agreement Wow
yeah because that's real that's what
that's the business I'm in you better
understand that stuff understand
otherwise you just no X's and O's I turn
this into a blackboard and I look like a
genius but when I get out there with a
real fighter
I won't stick that up my you know what
it ain't gonna help you can understand
what's really going on under pressure
how a person is thinking so I'm in a gym
that's my whole life I'm gonna gym
making finest in and if you don't go to
school get out of the gym yeah come in
late get out of here Teddy I'm 10
minutes late
yeah you didn't have to discipline to be
late you don't have to discipline to to
to do what you have to do in the ring
either were you feared will you feared
or respected I don't know I mean I'm not
in the Bronx Tale so I don't know when I
know you know what I'm talking I'm just
saying kidding around like it would be I
don't know the truth of it is
they believe me they just believe me I
again we all want to pat ourselves on
the back and and we want to be romantic
and we and you know someone like the guy
you mentioned before would probably say
it was feared it is and then like you
know they say well fear lasts longer
something like that but I was in a real
world
I was with real people having real
feelings I guess I guess my question
would be this this disappointed but I
just want to get maybe choice a right is
I'm always in a world with real people
with real kids that were having trouble
with these emotions and they saw what I
was telling them as a light to a dark
place that we're going into that's what
I want okay that that was lit in other
words I'm going into a scary place right
this guy's telling me what I need for
that light to see where the Freak I'm
going and and and and if I don't
understand that you know what I have no
shine it's scary enough that I'm going
into that and here's the thing I wanted
to say was at the end of the day I'm
doing this on living his life I'm doing
everything by the book
and by my instincts whatever those
instincts are they're growing and then
I'm forming fighters and like I said
you're late I get out of here Teddy owes
them get out of here you come in
tomorrow on time you could trade because
if you can't be on time if you can't
control yourself to be on time you you
can't control yourself in it so I'm
doing all this right and it was simple
it was black or white cars had a thing
hanging over his head he was getting
older he already knew whatever I didn't
know what it was to have champions he
already knew what it was to have Fame
and and all this stuff all I was doing
was going up I was just working I didn't
know there was anything underneath cuts
knew there was something underneath so
cuz when he started compromising himself
and making decisions that hurt me
that'll entice a goal and people
sometimes now years later they go hey
Ted you know you you made you you didn't
go what do you mean don't give me no
credit I was just his kid who I was
coloring by the numbers uh number one
red number two black
I shouldn't get any credit because I was
just doing where I didn't know that
there could be fame I didn't know that I
what it would feel like to have
champions and everything I was just
doing what I had to do to go forward and
cuz no cousin knew what it was and what
he might not have and he knew that the
clock was ticking cuz had an anvil of
his head that I didn't have and I
understand that now I understand that
let me ask you what is what is cusses a
motivation because you're saying he
never married anybody he married boxing
who was he trying to what was he trying
to prove I mean this is a guy that made
it out of highest level you know all
these champions all these people he's
built what was he doing it for what was
his motivation coming from he could make
people better
yeah but why continue doing it when you
keep doing it there's got to be a bigger
reason than just you know it can't be
money it's got to be something they
can't get credit for that he would want
get credit for it and that drove him the
recognition part or what could be what
money could ever satisfy knowing that
you can make champions what money could
everybody know that now gonna happen
yeah he can make champions he could make
champions he almost believed that he can
instill his will into somebody to be a
god that's a powerful statement you just
made that and did you see him do that
like when he's done your lion your
allele was he was he more a willpower
guy was amor a skill guy well you know
one of his sayings was to me as an 18
year old 19 Wow 21 22 he used to say
Teddy always remember this will always
defeat skill unless there wasn't unless
because he was a man of he was a
practical man and he and he had to have
those answers he said unless one man's
skill is so far superior that his will
never gets tested and that was Tyson as
will never gets tested
Tyson didn't have a strong will but he
had great great skills and when his
skills was so dominant which they wore
would stay wa for a long time till we
met somebody named Holyfield and Douglas
up until then his skills was sulfa he
was like one of those monster trucks
going over Volkswagen I mean it never
got tensed evokes my complaint have a
pretty good engine but you're all gonna
find out you because it got crushed it
might it might not because the body
wasn't wasn't able to tolerate what
maybe the engine later on could could
show you they could do so Tyson would
run over everybody with his great skills
and those people never got a chance to
find out where he was empty to look
inside to check those places to look
into you know to to just travel into
those places to find out where he might
be weak they didn't they didn't his
abilities never let him get to that
place never let him get tested until one
day he got tested did when one cussed
when cus I do you think he was borrowing
cusses will so when that when he died
his willpower also that is that do you
kind of see a parallel there or that
Dyson was greven because his will and
that's not something you can borrow but
what you're saying is will a cusp help
he can't impose his will on you for you
did you care
you can't I got it I mean you can make
somebody aware is something and if
they're willing to face what they have
to face once you make them aware of it
that they might not have been aware of
interesting you can help them but they
got be willing to face that devil at the
door you know that double knocks at the
door you know you can't just lock the
door mm-hmm
you know you got to be willing to say
you know true did you ever see anybody
that flipped that went from no willpower
to a little bit of willpower to a strong
willpower yeah okay
Bobby Holmes when he was in amateur yeah
and cons made me very aware of it and I
got all the v-spec for Larry he I hate
to say this but hey well I was a great
great great great champion and multi man
and you know what you can say things
because he got there he got there but I
think it makes him greater so I'm gonna
say it he was in a fight I think the guy
whose name was
don't ask me how I remember this and he
was in the averages and he lost the
fight in the amateur sir this guy
supposedly quit and cus would say you
know people said he was a dog and people
and that again that shows you again how
great Larry Holmes to overcome that
because you can't have courage if you
don't have fear
how you gonna have courage if you're not
scared of something what is courage
without being scared of something
coverage is overcoming courage is facing
something if there's nothing to overcome
nothing to face how did you show courage
you have to have fear you have to be
terrified to have courage yeah you have
to you have to almost be weak to have
courage you have to have a weak moment
to have courage because if you didn't
have a weak moment if you don't have the
moment of self-doubt of thinking about
submitting of quitting we hate to use
that word but then how would you have
courage how would you display what would
coverage be coverages is getting passed
as overcoming that's pulling you out of
that so if you don't have that to pull
you out of what it courage to college
didn't exist and as what does that have
no definition so he was in a fight and
he comes made me very aware of Larry you
know Larry Holmes when since I think it
was Nick Wells but whatever was and
according to what everyone said there he
quit he gave it and he was alone I think
he might afford to wane Barbic to when
the amateurs but anyway he gave it and a
lot of people said they didn't have any
worth for him or any hope for him you
don't think that he would be a great
fighter because he was a Cohiba yellow
because he wouldn't you know once once a
dog always a dog and cuz said to me
listen Teddy he's still young enough
he's still at a point where he has hate
to used his word he had an excuse he
wasn't developed enough to understand
that he could control that feeling and
that he should control that film
if he doesn't give up if you get some
help and he doesn't give up
he can become he can he can grow in that
area because if he was a guy cuz would
say Teddy if he was a guy who already
had 300 amateur fights and already you
know had 20 pro fights and he was doing
that you know dun dun gone but at this
point of development lack of development
if he wants to look he can still be
helped
he went on to be a world champion set a
record for most title defenses I think
he might approach y'all lose who I think
was the greatest heavyweight of all time
for a lot of reasons
Ali was right behind them just for me
but Ali was great of course but Larry
Holmes takes those right hands from
shavers
that's what cus said cuz said to me
because we watch the fight together and
cuz said there's a pro he became a pro
that was the greatest that was the
greatest continent cross could get you
he became Hall look he got hit that
right hand from Earnie Shavers who could
knock walls down with the right hand one
right hand he could knock walls down and
he got dropped and he got up he became a
pro teddy
he gave powerful he became a problem so
yeah this is somebody could get that
will hey there is true to Redemption
mm-hmm redemption is a beautiful feeling
by the way it is it isn't me let me ask
you this with the whole fear you know
you hear a lot of things with fear
versus danger fear is imagination danger
is real right you you hear this these
two words so to you you're saying
courage is there's no meaning to courage
if you don't have something to fear to
have to balance or to have to fight to
just happen to the fear but what is the
difference between fear and danger to
you
you're not in a fight okay you're not in
a fight until there's resistance up
until the point is resistance is
something to overcome it's just an
athletic venture you've shown how quick
you are how strong you are how good
save you are how smart you are how
tricky you are it's it's an exhibition
but then something happens and a moment
comes and you have to overcome you get
hurt
whatever and you have to overcome you
have to get through you have to deal
with resistance then you've been in a
fight then you show those qualities
those qualities have to be there then
you know the difference between what
your question was between fear and
danger and danger is you know danger
danger is physical fears emotional
they both do damage buddy and you know
that better than most people you know
that because you've been there you've
been in those you've walked down those
tunnels you know and I I trained those
New York Jets for three years I am it's
it's almost sad to say that they
actually put me in the press book as a
coach
back when mangini and Tanner bond was
the GM and the coach but they asked me
to come in and work with the team so I
did and they called me a coach I was a
coach but I gave him boxing lessons and
I talked to them and I would I go right
to the same places we're gonna fight I
don't care if you're playing football I
don't give you a lawyer I don't care if
you're a teacher that has to go into a
classroom that's not too easy to go into
and face these kids I don't give you a
board member that has to go in front of
people and talk but we're gonna fight
we're in a fight and the first thing I
would say to these guys went when I
first got their attention was hey we
won't go into these these dark rooms
it's just a matter of whether or not we
stay there or we get out and I used to
call the grave rooms
I said say listen when you are a Ewing
that you in the trenches you know you
got a 300-pound guy in front of you and
he's kind of Lee and he's strong and you
know he's gonna do something to you and
you still going into a gray room
he's still going into a little bit of a
gray room you know and then if you keep
going further down that corridor there's
a black rope
you better get out of that grave room
you but it's not moving this way towards
this towards this where there's a little
more like and and you know they
understood it I used to even use the
terms you know we used to talk about
salmon agreements and I used to say to
them you make selling agreements on the
line in there sometimes you make selling
agreements where you know you you you
don't really you look for the guy you
know to kind of do a waltz you know you
don't really you make a little silent
agreements in some ways do we do that in
life you know yeah I used to say here's
the tangible part of giving it in
fighting guy starts throwing it don't
hit me punch when I was doing the ESPN
ringside fights that I would use that
term all these twelve don't hit me what
do you mean don't have any punches you
don't hit me I won't hit you don't just
just don't hit me
I look like Bank not that because that I
hurt the guy and then the guy's gonna
respond and he might hurt your back but
you told don't hit me you know don't hit
me I won't hit you don't so I would say
to the alignment do you ever suppose
don't hit me blocks Wow and you know
what some of these honest guys coach I
yeah coach yep I there - a couple don't
hit me high where I'm supposed to be you
know and and then listen and what is it
what are you afraid of well it's the
physical fear you you've hit it right on
the head you know it's the physical
danger the physical danger but it's it's
also the emotional of being embarrassed
of failing
of being found out none of us want to be
found out that's powerful
NASA yes sir that's the world you're in
where you are gonna be found out yeah
that's the best apart let me ask you how
much of cusses style when you watch cus
how much of it was let you say you're
somebody is training Teddy let's see how
bad you want it let's see if you--if you
got it let's see if you got the goodies
let's see if you can fight through your
fear let's see if you got and how much
ever was
you can do it Teddy go get him go kick
his ass because it's a different style
of leadership right it's a complete
different style leadership which which
style was custom or was it a complete
different style than what I'm talking
about no cuz was about teaching because
was about believing because was about
substance tangible that sooner or later
the ring was a chamber of truth so like
someone's gonna figure out you could be
as small you want they're gonna get in
they're gonna figure out you were full
of crap that your stuff ain't helping
them the chamber of truth your stuff
ain't helping them you you better you
better tell the truth you better tell
them what they're what what's their
what's common what what they're gonna be
facing and and part of the way you tell
me is he explained to him like I would
talk to find this and I would say and
cuz would say yeah there you go
see I told you a great leader you know
again he's not paying me as keep it had
to give me something bump me up but I
was I was progressing and I would say to
you know I would talk about the things
that it'll make sense to talk about that
I knew they were failing before before
it came out and opened to let him know
that I understood they I understood what
was there what they would think when I
took kids amateur kids when I was the
power was time to take him to fights I
take him down to south box they get
fights and I would have him sitting in a
locker room dressing awake and I have a
young kid you know the way you're
supposed to look like
and I come by but I knew they were dying
so I come by and say you know I didn't
even say that your shirt movement joking
around like and the hard part I didn't I
you know I could hardly tell you sir and
the kid go
I think if they can't help it they could
do it I said no it's not showing I said
it's not showing but I know how you feel
like because he was you know and then
sometimes we'd be going down and we'd be
driving down in a station wagon right
going down you know where we're going
we ain't going to have ice cream we're
not go on the Dairy Queen we're going to
fight in the South Bronx in club shows
smokers tough place so we're driving and
I used to say any kids so how many in
wish and I get a flat tire right about
now no we don't know flat tire teddy
I don't know all right a few years later
when the kids were out of box and they
were growing up they were someone going
to college you know I'm proud of all
these kids
Teddy remember when you said we were
hoping you get a fun set but we knew
you'd fix it
Wow God so you so so because when I read
about you telling you tested your guys
you gave them you gave them the bleep is
this story true by you testing a Michael
Moore when he's coming to the corner you
take you're not gonna sit down right now
I'm gonna sit down
stand up you haven't earned the right to
say that did you say things like that
your guys or no yeah it's on tape so you
can't can kind of hide from it you know
I'm just glad it's on tape when you said
it to Michael yeah okay yeah it was on
HBO so this it's there to see but I mean
I'm just glad he didn't say yeah you sit
down you you go find I'm glad that he
that he did what he did which was behave
like a guy want to be a champion how
different is it when he said I didn't do
that that's one thing that should be
really clear I didn't win that fight
against Holyfield he did mm-hmm
I did my job but he more importantly he
did his job he did his job and he
freakin did it good how different how
much to how different is it we're at the
gym your trainer with
and I'm looking good okay and you're
working with me and you're testing me
I'm looking good I'm going to a couple
things you're watching I'm doing good
and then it's the real fight
how much do you change and how much do
you learn about the guy that you're
training so the steady change in the
corner different than the way you're
training me at the gym or no no okay but
but it's but re reminders yeah okay
listen I don't they're gonna hear some
of the same things they heard every day
in the gym they're gonna hear sometimes
nothing weird no but but it becomes more
intensified you know it becomes that
that that beam of Sun going into the
prison glass and it's still a beam of
Sun and you're still getting light and
you're still getting a Sun every day but
now when you put that when you put that
on you know that prison glass there that
magnifying glass there it comes out a
little stronger a lot stronger well this
is the moment this is the moment baby
this is it does everything we trained
for so I'm gonna be a little bit more
stronger and and forceful about it then
I might have been in the gym or put it
this way
more concentrated you know it's it's
it's still the detergent you're putting
on your clothes but this is the high the
stuff that's more just more concentrated
and it's strong who's that who's the guy
you saw over the years who you would say
you the best in skill set the best in
skill and then who would you say you've
seen over the years who was the best in
the will as a fighter oh wow I mean
there's so many in great skills
I mean Sugar Ray Leonard was a great
skill guy you know Mayweather great
skill guy you know and he had great
wheels too but then usually it's the guy
with less skill that might have too
great a will because he needs it there
was a there was a kid years ago named
Danny little red Lopez it's back in the
70s in the 80s I used to watch what cuz
good right hand poncho but he got hit
too much
but man he knocked everyone out he beat
everyone he got on the floor got off the
floor
Alan Pryor oh my god before drugs got a
whole damn what a will he had he wins
the title against the guy named kid pom
Polly Antonio Cervantes a great fighter
he wins the time some guys can't like
have free rights when they fight for the
time you know they get soft too touches
nothing here
he fights Cervantes he gets dropped he
gets far as they're counting because he
got a given a count and Cervantes is
waiting for them to count right they
counting prior prior does a backflip and
and the referee is like what's going on
here
hey hey and like he's trying to sort
things out here and and here's Pryor
doing this and and Cervantes is like
melting right and funny like an ice
cream on a July day like like what oh
wait like like I got the skills
obviously I just put him on the floor
but what is this guy guy [ __ ] so that
was one of the greatest worlds I ever
saw was having prior to be honest with
you and and the ones that I you know
what I just touched on you know that I
just that I mentioned on the skill side
Leonard and Mayweather
yeah Mayo the Leonard Ali Ali skill and
we'll yeah because there was two alleys
you know the first alley was before that
three and a half year layoff when he
refused to go on the army where he beat
you with speed and skill and then after
three and a half years or if he didn't
have that anymore and he had to find
something that he never knew he had to
that level complete complete well I mean
I'm talking about supreme will cuz once
told me there was only two fighters he
ever saw that had supreme confidence
that they believed there was no way that
you could beat them Sugar Ray Robinson
in Muhammad Ali that they had that and
it was a quality just as important more
important than speed or power footwork
to quali just like I believe that
character in a person is acquire I
believe Tyson didn't have it and it
finally showed up his skill got him to
wit I don't don't give
wrong but character that that sooner or
later sooner or later you're gonna need
that that that that is that's gonna show
up that if that if you're missing it
it's it's gonna show but sooner or later
you because people say well define
character Teddy like I can understand
speed I understand power
I understand slickness but what do you
mean that characters or quality how
about being dependable when you rather
have a friend that's dependable than one
that's not dependable I would well
wouldn't you rather have a fighter
that's dependable than one that's not
that's character and when the moment
came was Tyson dependable I'm not
knocking him I'm gonna tell you now so
those haters out there that are sir all
30 of the one of the greatest punches
ever one of the greatest combinations of
speed and power ever one of the greatest
switch hitters like Mickey Mantle that
could hit them on the left side or the
right side of the plate lefty or righty
could could knock you dead you know one
of the greatest finishers ever when he
hurt you I mean he and all those things
so I'm the first to say that but he
wasn't dependable he wasn't dependable
because when he had to be dependable he
was off somewhere else he was in there I
want a guy was dependable I want a
friend who's dependable Shh you know
it's crazy there's a book out there
called something about CEOs and they did
a research on what qualities of a an
employee helped them eventually become a
CEO of a company and it was reliability
which is the same as being dependable
and it was number one above everybody
else when people said why do you enjoy
following the CEO they would say because
he is reliable and eventually he ends up
having a group of people that want to
work form because he's relying where's
merely about cost right so how old's me
early about how cool what he wanted me
to be mm-hmm I had to be reliable as a
teacher because if you lie to these guys
and they get in the ring and that
freaking stuff is common oh oh holy crap
he didn't tell me the truth
I couldn't rely on what he told me you
taught people if I'm a guy for you and
I'm not ready
fight someone who would tell me I'm not
ready to fight that guy would you tell
me that if I'm your fighter are you
kidding me yeah how would you how would
you have that conversation with me you
ain't ready for a ball at an earlier
stage I've actually told some people not
to box anymore I don't know he's retired
get out of the game yeah because I
didn't think that they could get to the
place to a place to make impact money to
to be able to really be worth it for
them where they where it would be
worthwhile the diverse they were taken
is the risk of course all right not just
a risk physical risk but risk of time a
risk a risk of of involvement a risk of
would you dedication would you dedicate
dedicate yourself if you're not gonna be
able to have a chance to get there take
that same dedication and use if it's
somewhere you can't get to I had a kid
years ago when I had Tyson up there
great kid great kid and he was a
heavyweight he played a little football
a pretty good level he went to Lehigh
with a scholarship you know I think that
was Division one I think he got a cup of
tea with the Cleveland Browns you know
just like a quick try out whatever
physical guy and heavyweight he wasn't
gonna make it I mean you know he he
could be okay but he wasn't gonna make
it
they came a moment where there was state
police tests were coming up up there and
he came to me great kid great person he
came to me said Teddy what do you think
take the State Police test yeah and you
know what I've been diving back touch
with him but I heard he's in BCI I
already moved up the ladder future
boxing you was the future box and I'm
obviously I'll give you mine I want to
hear what you're gonna say about this on
what I feel about the world of boxing I
used to be a fan ice to follow it I
enjoyed it I don't believe it anymore
because I think there's way too much
politics and I have that Buster here I
had Joe Cortez here we've had some of
these guys we've sat down and they're so
well you know the scoring system is now
working because the best way to really
have judges look at the fight this from
the top Joe said you got to look at the
judge another best ways I have honest
judges okay so that's where I'm going
with this so how much how much does that
affect the game of boxing the world of
boxing with Jason fans
it's Jason fans it hurts the credibility
of the sport but has been around 200
years so it's not going away you don't
think that's gonna change it does judge
because people think these these people
had Hollywood and all these stars and
all these and they they all come out for
the big fights why why it's the same
reason that people go to Lourdes to get
the waters to maybe they're gonna get a
little healed maybe maybe the waters
will help them they will heal them they
come to those fights because maybe they
could get better maybe they can see real
men in the ring noble warriors facing
their inhibitions facing their doubts
facing all the dog spots inside
themselves and going in there and being
better maybe I could be better if I get
close to these guys and I watch that's
why they all come out maybe I could get
touched by it maybe maybe I could face
something a little bit better maybe the
next time that my boss is coming down
the hallway I don't go and hide in the
water fountain and let water run in my
mouth while I'm not drinking just
waiting for this freaking guy to leave
maybe I get stronger maybe I get tougher
maybe I become more you think that's
what it is it's draws people it draws
them to see a man face another man with
all the weaknesses that we have inside
ourselves all the fears all the doubts
all the inhibitions all the crap that
happened to us as a kid all the stuff
that was taught us that we were yellow
we were this we were no good we were all
gonna be this we weren't gonna be that
and to go in and see two men face
themselves and face all those things
today it ain't the other stuff it's what
you're facing about yourself inside what
you don't know and be willing to find
out to know people want to be around
that and I'll tell you one other thing
that makes boxing great I think there's
too many excuses in life anyway I gotta
say that but sometimes
sometimes people will say life's not
fair all right I know you can go on the
other side and say you got to make it
fair you gotta I get it I get it
I would but sometimes you could say you
know what it's tough you get born with
certain genes you get born by certain
parents you get one of certain places
certain colors certain I don't believe
there's anything that holds you back now
well we've as a country we've we've got
past that but sometimes you feel that if
you feel it and if you feel it it could
be real
it don't mean it's real but your feeling
you think it's real
and then that you have poverty you
didn't have this [ __ ] in you know yeah
your clothes you [ __ ] a little
embarrassed because you were wearing
hand-me-downs and and your shoes had
some holes in them and all this stuff
that you didn't think was fair all this
stuff and then on one given night he
could get in the ring and if you are
prepared enough if you determined enough
if you care enough you can be cold
champion of the world
wow that's pretty freakin good that's
why people come that's why they call
them to see that to witness that you UFC
versus boxing I'm curious your thoughts
on UFC vs. boxing obviously UFC is
coming up tremendously right now it's
getting a lot of credibility right now
do you think there will come a time
where US is gonna take over boxing no
you don't think I haven't been around
200 years and boxing is just what I just
said and it's the problem with boxing
and the reason why UFC they have their
own market it's like having two
restaurants you know but but you're
still seeing people going in both places
say now another restaurant this
restaurants gonna close
no because they still have patrons they
still are people that like that food
there's still two different markets
people like this food and they like this
food so you're still gonna have it but
Dana White has done a great job of
marketing
his brand marketing his sport developing
his sport you know it helps to be a
dictator sometimes I know I know you
know I mean if you don't kill nobody
you know if you could be if you could be
completely in control like Dana White is
and you say hey you fight this guy you
fight this guy I'm only putting
competitive you don't like it hit it
highway 99 it's to make a left and to
rights and if you can controlled it like
that you can make you proud of good and
get away with it and that's part of why
he gets away with it
I'm not knocking him I'm saying that
that it works and that that's part of
why he built up his sport but boxing you
know the NBA has a national commission
if you haven't heard that an NHL if you
haven't heard has a national commission
and uh MLB every one of the the football
NFL the International Commission to put
rules and enforce rules for the benefit
of the sport I say it again not for the
benefit of Tom Brady even though he
might have had a few soft footballs he
was throwing over there I don't know he
might have got away with that one but
for the benefit of de-spawn I just don't
have dad who the Frick is saying you got
losses you got abide by the rules for
the bet there is no Nationals are you've
got a bunch of these freaking lowlife I
should be careful but what the hell it's
too late I mean well it was still some
of these promoters that they only care
about their own little piece of property
and they control that piece of property
they do they don't they don't give a fig
about the sport in boxing or new UFC and
Don foxy boxing boxing that's the
difference boxing has a bunch of not a
bunch maybe four or five powerbrokers if
that many that that have the networks
that have the power that have two stable
fighters they have to control and they
don't care about the sport about they
can't put their piece of land so they
don't care and fight his fight
competitor fights as long as they get to
20 and all 25 and all and they're on TV
and they're getting big checks they
don't care if the supporters driving how
do they control them they don't care
they don't care if a judge gives a
corrupt decision as long as it's corrupt
on their side of the fence because they
don't they don't care about twenty years
down the road they don't care about the
the sport of all they care about the
diamond could
so that they still have power how do you
do it you have to have a national
commission so let me ask you a question
though if David if they know white ran
boxing he would have made the Mayweather
Pacquiao fight at the peak is what your
son's boxing I get that what if if it
was if it was ran it obviously can't
revert back there could be such a thing
as the Nationals on boxing yeah yeah he
would say no yeah we got you're gonna
fight this is what you got a fast you
don't want to do not fight noble and
maybe he would also so they have their
problems too but maybe he would also say
after a horrible decision where you'd
have to be like yeah I don't know yeah
yeah I mean you'd have to be unlike a
lot of Psychiatry medicine I guess I'd
have to be taken a lot of hallucinogens
to make a decision away some of these
judges make well you know the other guy
won and maybe Dana White and could come
in or Czar could come in and say hey you
were the judge come to my office Monday
morning we're gonna watch this tape and
if you don't have a damn good
explanation of how you frickin scored
this fight for the other guy start
looking for another job right away
that's powerful then Dana would do
something like that because Dana right
after the fight will say I don't know if
I agree with this I don't know if I
agree with that and half the time people
are ticked off at this guy but he's
running the show you know how many fans
come up to me every day and they say
Teddy thanks for telling the truth but
now your sport these those decisions
what you're saying but Teddy what you're
saying is the reason why I agree I don't
know I mean with the way it's going
right now look how many fights he's
putting like how many exposures gonna go
like how much social media one company's
ultimate fighters like this stuff I mean
you look at boxing right now who's the
biggest poll right now you got Canelo's
pulling the Latino fights okay let's
just say Canelo
Golden Boy side right on the
heavyweights at who do you have wilder
okay fury Joshua after the fight you
know he wants to go be friends I don't
know if that's like this talyvel
heavyweight you know I don't even know
if the fans wants to see this like you
lost man don't
Oh Ruiz like who is who is the pole
today
who is the pole today where you're
sitting there saying like right now you
know it's a fox
you're right you're a thousand percent
right but you know it saves it it's kind
of like living in a place with rains
every frickin day and you're just about
to freak and say I can't take this no
more I cannot take this straight anymore
and then over such bulk you have a sunny
day how do you want to know how you got
the Thrilla in Manilla every once in a
while you have the last one week but
every once in a while you have a great
fight you do every once in a while you
you have to ran and let it every once in
a while
and that's what saves it what's the last
one oh we've had a few pretty good ones
give me a good one like like a gaudy
versus oh yeah Adi was always in great
that's like um that wasn't even making
momentum is a movie yeah what was sick
you know oh it's a great you can watch
that over and over and over again fights
like that makes me spend thousands that
kind of fights some of these fights
right now you're watching a for what
you're watching it for I don't object
again I don't want to go off track here
I'm just asking because I'm really value
you see what you think no no no but I
will ship but you do get them you do
still be the last one to steady no you
had one just not too long ago I'm just
coming up short right now okay um it was
just it's just I'm trying to remember
which one it was
I mean I had a kid involved in a fight
better be of the light heavyweight he
was the IBF champion against my kid the
WBC champion vozack Ukrainian against a
Russian kid and on tremendous fight we
came up short but uh I was on espn2 many
times you have a against B you're right
it's like a farm system it's like like
they're just the the promoters are using
the network's their network some of the
executives like they're not the
brightest guys in the world sometimes
just because takes anchors don't
automatically mean that they're geniuses
and but they have a product to cells and
then they taste and they stay there
they're there
they've been put there and they're there
you know certain places and so you know
you got but yeah you got a lot of a lot
of times on television on these
different networks
you got the eight kids to be in
executives don't know what's going on
that the promoters using them to build
their stable phase again where it's not
competitive they're just building their
guys up but on that fight was we lost
but um it was a tremendous fight and
then before that spence spence and
porter welterweights that was about
maybe a month ago
that's not lo long ago that was two guys
with wills and skills I'll tell you
right now Spence had the better skills
but Porter man he had tremendous will
and you know what he was winning the
fight on my scorecard going into the
late rounds but then the other guys
skill and he had some will allowed him
to come back and it was a really it was
really a tremendous fight so they're
still there you think doc King was good
for the game
I want to give an honest answer and
takes a second to think about it you've
robbed fighters disrespect to fight his
hurt fighters but he also it's like kind
of like asking if you made the Rocky
movie was Rocky good for boxing the
Rocky movie was fictional it was you
know wasn't real but it brought a lot of
fans to the game mm-hmm
King brought a lot of fans of the game
he put on extravagant events while key
events in in way off places like Zaire
where it brought attention to where
we're still talking about it to him yeah
so I guess that's your answer he has
helped yeah I mean you can't get around
it but but I qualified it by saying what
I said first because that's fair who's
the modern day down I mean Don King
anybody today that's doing it at his
level the way he did it Oh
I mean Errol Errol is a guy that's been
around 60 years now and he's you know he
got fortunate that he he was about to go
out of the game
my frankly HBO was and wasn't doing
really anything with him anymore and I
and then ESPN saves him and he's with
ESPN now and you know he's definitely
the biggest promoter in the game
probably and then you got guys like
Eddie horns with with his own you know
you got him there one of it ignorant
boxers as a trainer of mine local guy
here he's part of the zone but it at
that level of a Don King today at that
level like you know if you put Don and
Dan I forget about character and all
that stuff the way you described on you
put down in Dana who's the better
promoter
I mean Dana hasn't had the longevity
that King had first of all longevity has
to be factored in there right a little
bit and but for Dana saw they just put
in some big events on in a short period
of time he's catching up
you think he must I know you just spent
some time with Maz Vidal which you know
his fight would be as yeah
comes across as a good person like a
character guy do you think his a request
to want to fight Canelo is a disease to
have a standing chance to go against a
guy like that or no probably not
probably not okay I mean we talk to
truths right yeah sure I come and listen
that's why he's a guy that I could like
because they see me tomorrow and
everything you say teddy hey yeah I
understand you're saying that he won't
be one of these guys he's trying to play
it yeah and try to put a front on but
listen in his mind if he believes that
then it's the truth for him it's the
truth for him for me you asked me a
question from liya from where I sit and
I think that listen should anybody be
look badly at for trying to do something
Titanic for their families for
themselves something huge like kind of
kind of agreement did with Mayweather he
had no chance with Mayweather mm-hmm but
he was able to sell it by saying that he
could beat him and enough people
believed it to make it to make it
something that there was a historic with
the money they made you blame somebody
no I don't shooting for that no I don't
mean you have to believe yeah then it's
that it's gonna happen but you see that
this goes back to it like think about it
right now how many people wanted to see
that fight with him and Nick right there
Diaz who this is like a good fight right
this comes tremendous fight and now
khabib you know he you know now counter
Dana's saying there's no way Conor could
fight a guy like Mazda because he's too
big for him right but but there's
excitement there so oh I want to see
that Conor good fight Mazda don't know
no they interesting there's no way in
the world that wouldn't have you good
match they couldn't find it no because
because Jorge's way too big for counter
that's what Dana's talking about Canelo
no no no Conor McGregor fighting Maas
Vidal yeah that Maas Vidale is too big
for counter because Connor wants to
fight him but guys have moved up and
waiting I know they have but but Dana
say he would you say yeah but what I'm
saying is if there's the excitement
there's the excitement of the micro
spring pumped up to heavyweight to show
Larry Holmes yeah he went from 175 to 2
whatever because almost was like what to
2230 whatever somewhere in that
neighborhood maybe a little less and he
moved up he worked at it the right way
we went about it the right way and he
won you know so I would say listen I
give credit to Dana so you would want to
see a counter my mother though you would
want to see that fight I you would want
to say count on what listen if it was
something that could be intriguing to it
and I think mother dogs earned the right
to shoot for something like that to be
able to average it because there's
certain kinds you can make more money
with it's just the way it is it's just
the way it is McGregor has that gift of
gab here he's got that special
promotional gene he's a great promoter
may Blair was a great promoter nobody
was greater than Ally and they were
great wrestlers that Ally took from to
go joy gorgeous George and all those
guys Ali would tell you the truth I took
from those guys you know so they have a
PhD in it and and McGregor's got a PhD
in that and four and Muslims just he's
recognizing that that hey listen I could
go bust my butt all day long and I ain't
never gonna make the money I could make
with this guy that has a PhD in
promotion now I'm not saying that it
would be that it would be the greatest
fight but I'm saying that I give my I
would buy it because I would buy I
believe in Mazda door I believe I think
McGregor was good to it his at his level
but I'm just saying I believe that he's
earned the right to venture into those
places
he's a boxing guy that's excited about
us see see that's the part it's pulling
even a guy like you did at UFC Slyke
last thing before we wrap up here
obviously one of the reasons why we got
connected I wish it was a different
reason but one of the reasons why it you
know you really are I say with Sammy
Sammy the bull Gravano there's a chapter
in your book about Sammy you know I read
it I mean obviously it's a very very
interesting chapter the relationship
with you and just son all this stuff
what what it when you saw Sammy's
response when I asked him the question
of fear and I'm sure people send it to
you say hey Teddy watch what Sammy said
but you Teddy Atlas said to me one day
are you afraid I said no I didn't say I
don't have fear
I said no Teddy Atlas is an [ __ ] was
the first thing I came to mom when he
saw that consistent is the same guy you
know he's not honest you know he I think
that um I think there's a combination of
things I think one of them is that he's
not relevant and trying to find a way to
become relevant you know he's trying to
become get attention become important
again and maybe use somebody to become
important again I think that I just
think that um it's the consistent you
know that he could never and we talked
about it earlier that you know if you if
you deny something if you deny something
that's in all of us which is fear how
can you have overcome it if you deny it
if you won't face it oh isn't that sort
of the definition of being cowardly that
you won't face something I mean that if
we don't use such a powerful word as
cowardly isn't that avoiding something
that we God doesn't let us avoid nature
if people are uncomfortable with hearing
me talk about God all right I respect
that
I'll call nature nature has put fear in
all of us so we can be better so we can
overcome things if we don't understand
that we are fear and we say we don't
have it well like I've always said two
fighters two real fighters either liar
or you need to go to a doctor and find
out what the figures wrong with you
because everyone has it you have it why
don't we walk across the street and look
both ways
we're not cowards but we are fear well
we have fear because we might get hit by
a car so we look because we don't want
to get hit by a car could that be being
cautious it's fear
you think it's called caution but it's
an element of fear it's an element of
being afraid of getting hit by a car
yeah use the word question it's
comfortable but if we're gonna get down
to the nitty-gritty its fear it's fear
that we could get killed now we could
get maimed I mean you were getting a
palace I'm just saying that when you I
didn't listen to it I just heard what
people told me so I only have snippets
of it but you know it's just consistent
with a guy that's never gonna be able to
be truthful about because he always
looked at it like he always looked at it
like it was a shortcoming like in his
world it would be a shortcoming well
guess what you proved that you had a
shortcoming by what it did so no matter
what he says you know that old saying
the horse is out of the barn somebody
should tell him the horse left upon a
long time ago we already know that he's
afraid because why did he do what he did
he did it because he was afraid he was
afraid of facing what was common I mean
somebody should remind him say he Sam
listen I know you don't like to listen
to her but bow you've been exposed to
ready
he already proved that you're afraid I
won't even use the word a coward I can
use it but I won't
but you've already proved that because
of your woman you would have faced what
was coming you really said come on but
instead you found the way out when the
fight comes when the moment comes
fighters fight they don't find ways out
you know how to fight it you shouldn't
even use that word shouldn't even you
you know what you want you're a freaking
you're with one of those yuppies that
that orders stop ugh
vanilla lattes on the app the only
differences you order emerges instead of
lattes and and because you didn't have
the guts to do the murders yourself
although it doesn't take much guts to
shoot someone behind the head that's
what you are
go get the Starbucks app and order some
frickin vanilla lattes okay but don't
bother me then forget it here I know
what you are I know what you're not I
know what you're not to stop the BS what
else your talk you spending you with him
how was he when you spending you're with
him I mean you trained his son you guys
were at the gym together you guys were
you know he would come and ask you
questions what was he like I mean you
wouldn't spend a year with him if you
guys didn't get along that long you guys
said there was no good I in relationship
at some point there right yeah I mean he
he liked boxing and he reached out to a
relationship he was training at
Gleason's Gym and Brooklyn on to the
bridge I was trying to fight his there
and he reached out to me because you
know he was training he was training
with a with Edwin Viet who was a real
fighter who was a guy who fought Durant
forth I ran and 15 rounds he won would
yeah yeah he's a real fighter but but
also he's a guy who you know he didn't
make money in boxing real money and he
needed a way to make money so we would
let's say me pay him to let him hit him
and not him back is that is that going
in and if I wasn't afraid I wouldn't get
into is that really getting in the ring
is it oh gee really I know a lot of
people to do it that way there being a
line out the door you could do it with a
guarantee that guy won't hit you oh wow
that's that's like saying I'll go in the
K to a lion but make sure the Lions got
no teeth
and no cause I'm alive does that make me
a line and fighter will this make me
fight a guideline that has no teeth and
no claws and it's not a lion anymore
it was a lion by the way has teeth and
claws and can kill you a fighter by the
way can hurt you if he's allowed to hit
you so listen hi yeah I was I was in a
gym with him he reached out to me one
day you know asked me to train him
instead of Edwin he said I think you'd
be a better trainer for me and I said no
and then one day Edwin was away with a
fighter and he came to me and said he's
away today would you do it I'll pay ya
there ain't gonna take no money I do you
a favour of training for the day one day
they did and then that grew into later
on we worked out in a weightlifting gym
together mmm you know for a year and
that was that that's all that's all true
and I trained him for that one day and
after that one day you know of course he
said that's the style I should be
learning and I'd like you to I said I
told you for one day I'd do it you know
and then he offered me I mean you won't
go into it he offered me he offered me
he said me and my partner I know who his
partner was I mean a guy named John
Gotti we want to get into the boxing
business we'll give you $75,000 seed
money those were his words
and um pay yeah I think it was two
thousand a week and buy a building put
in your name I was thinking to myself
I'm gonna listen you know that old silly
saying you know I was born at night but
not last night you know I mean I'm not
the smartest guy but I'm not two
stupidest stupidest guy in the world you
know and you know I do care about other
things other than just saying oh you'd
be nice because I didn't have a lot then
I didn't have much at all to be honest
but I also I was okay about how it would
affect my family you know see that to me
that's part of being brave that's part
of not being a coward that's part of
showing something more than just saying
you're tough kind of tough guy cares
about what's gonna happen to us
but father kid tough guy cares about the
collateral damage to consider people I
knew that if I did that I said hey I
pick a gamble what the fake I knew what
that would do to my kids I I even
laughed to myself one time when he said
we put the goat in your name I said the
indictment still I mean you know I mean
yeah I didn't say that loud but the
indictments are being my name I think -
very clear Theodore
a hapless because when you in court it
they're not gonna say teddy so you know
so he offered me although and I said no
there was no BS and around it
I took a meeting with him and all his
wise guy friends and you know do me a
favor you just take a meeting and and
yes or no yes or no this way they can
hear it out of your mouth they don't you
know talking about would have this we
have this we have this way there's no no
that was it
so yeah that's the story with you on
Sammy did you relate to any part of
Sammy as as character or not at all that
one year you got spent on together was
there any like a chip or anything to
prove like did you see anything where I
saw out there gaudy like you and him
similar did you see anything or not
listen I I saw a guy well be careful I
don't want to just say something the
sake of saying it or for vengeance or
anything like that I want to say for the
truth
I saw a guy that sometimes said time
went on I wondered it's kind of like
seeing a fighter like that can't face
what you have to face ultimately in the
ring like he's become a state trooper
you know like we talked earlier huh
become something you know what I mean
I kind of saw like a guy who obviously
his vocation was a gangster right and
when when he when he starts saying I
ain't afraid of nothin and you know you
know and then starts asking you
questions like you know I I'm not of how
do you help fight this how do you make
them control themselves they said you
mean their fear oh I don't have fear Oh
like you just it's just like you want a
witness then you just said guilty I mean
that wasn't hard to figure out yeah you
don't have fear and no it's how do you
talk I suppose you got a control feels
like fire fire and then like that's used
fire like you can't even like how's this
guy gonna be what you gotta be when you
get in the ring eventually you gotta
face the devil right you gotta face that
moment you gotta fake that guy that's
gonna come to you in the ring and say
you ready to do this
you've been hurt you're ready to do this
you ready to be a fighter
forget about being a fast guy forget
about being a power punch and forget
about shootin guys in the head are you
ready to be a fighter are you ready to
be a gangster are you ready I kind of
thought it ain't ready but that's his
problem that's his thing growing up in
Staten Island were you ever close did
you ever associate yourself with any of
the gangsters because I know you know
Godfather was obviously shot there and
some of these guys Gianni Russo some of
those guys came from Staten Island were
you close to any of these guys are not a
zoning rules of actor I know please
let's be careful I didn't say he's a
gangster but he's from but he's from
whatever he was a guy that was a
associate I Costello years ago
yeah and they governed him quick in the
Godfather so I don't know about him I
mean to me there was more significant
people around than him but listen it was
a there was I think everyone knows that
there was I mean Castellano lived on top
of total over the house that he called
the White House I mean you know there
was a good amount of gangsters on stand
up I mean did I associate with them no I
wasn't hanging out and playing pinochle
with him but I guess obviously people
know each other you know and and when
you're in the boxing business you when
you're from stand out people you know
people gravitate towards boxing if you
haven't noticed I know yeah you know
they gravitate towards they you know so
there were guys I knew but they
gravitate towards it because of kind of
the same reason actors gravitate to what
we talked about earlier they they think
that you know there's there's something
to this facing things being a man you
know and it doesn't mean there is unless
you are unless you are this is gonna
bless it now with you man they surely
this has been a blessing now and talking
to you man you just a very real guy and
the story when you start off with your
father I immediately connected with you
because my dad I'll tell you a crazy
story you're so Middle Eastern fathers
there is no I love you Teddy there is
none of that it's it's just you're not
working hard enough you got to go do
something with your life when you're
gonna get your act to get it's a lot of
that right so I get out of the military
and since since I was a kid man I enjoy
this guy's company you would leave five
o'clock in the morning would come home
at nine o'clock so it's always a similar
way of trying to get this guy's
attention to say hey what do you think
about your son here so one day I come
out of the army and I'm working at
Bally's the night before I go to it out
to his house and I said listen I got to
tell you something says what I say you
gotta tell me you love me
it says what are you talking about I
said tell me I love you he says you have
become an American what is this
Americans
I said tell me you love me I'm your son
I said we got to hear it from you he
says I'm not gonna tell you I love you
you know I love you I said dad I'm
telling you right now I want to hear it
he says Gus this is crazy this is crazy
how did you become like this
so I leave I go to work the next day my
dad never calls my work ever I get a
call Patrick made David line one that's
your father like my dad don't call me so
pick up the phone I say hey what's up
yeah yeah how you doing good I'm at work
okay all right that's good you're
working okay I love you click so that my
sister calls me she says is that health
Oh cancer why so he just call me and now
today you know the guys you can't help
him sell but tell you know you one of my
luckiest moments is the fact that my
kids are close to this guy you know it's
heaven on earth seen those moments so
yeah I appreciate you opening government
I truly wasn't expecting this interview
go to this direction but I had a blast
with you the last name change truly no
really man I really enjoyed this and
everybody watching this and I was just
told that his book Atlas you got to get
it the audible version just came out
right we're gonna put the link below for
you to go download the audible version
and it's him speaking it's Teddy's voice
speaking and then on top of that he also
has a charity that he started due to his
father we're gonna put the link below as
well free to find out more about it and
if we're gonna put Teddy social media as
well if you want to go give him love
after watching his weather is Twitter
matter we'll put his handle and my
handle here sent us a tweet and let us
know was your biggest takeaway from this
interview about Teddy appreciate you so
much for coming up you really enjoyed it
thank you
you
[Music]